الخلافات بين فرنسا والمانيا لم تمنع
الرئيس الفرنسي
والمستشار الالماني ولافشورس في الذكرى
الستين لتوقيع معاهده المصالحه بين
البلدين من اظهار ابتسامات عريضه تعكس
ربما اعلنا بانما يسمى بالمحرك الفرنسي
الالماني مازال قادرا على اعاده تاسيس
البناء الاوروبي في حقبه تقرع فيها الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا اجراس خطر يهدد
اوروبا برلين وباريس تتعاهدان بمواصله
الوقوف الى جانب اوكرانيا اكثر من اي وقت
مضى
هذه الحرب لكن نعله اوكرانيا ان تدرك اننا
لن نستسلم سنستمر في دعمنا لكن في اطاره
مبدا التنسيقي والعمل المشترك
حول الذهاب بعيدا في مسار ارسال دبابات
قتاليه ثقيله لكيف
في ما يتعلق بدبابات الكلير طلبت من وزير
الجيوش ان ينظر في الامر لا شيء مستبعدا
لكننا ننظر الى الامر من زاويه الموقف
الجماعي في اطار ثلاثه معاايير الا يكون
هذا الدعم تصعيديا ثانيا ان يكون هذا
الدعم فعليا وفعلا لاصدقائنا الاوكرانيين
وثا الا يضعف من قدراتنا الدفاعيه خاصه
البناء الحساسه
اذا لم يستجب الاتحاد الاوروبي بقوه
وبتمويل كبير للخطه الامريكيه لدعم
الطاقات النظيفه